Stephanie is in Pittsburgh hi Stephanie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi thank
you for taking my call um I am
questioning I am one baby step number
two I have a lot of student loans that a
lot at six figures and I wanted to lift
some of it'll be forgiven in ten years
because I'm a teacher there's to be out
of death and oh then that's Istanbul but
and that that's the challenge I like do
I waste time here no or not um okay
because that was my next question is and
what should i do while I'm waiting for
10 years like because I have a 40,000
and the beneficiary IRA I have about
eight ninety five hundred in my bank
accounts I've been saving money because
of the every dollar as I've been putting
money away
what do you mean beneficiary IRA and
inherited IRA yes yes they called it yes
suddenly because like that x-play and so
I have that money okay
it's taxable so I would pay the taxes on
that and throw it at your student loans
immediately what are you all on your
student loans I know about 185 thousand
to be a teacher yes yes yes and it's
because I didn't it's my fault I didn't
work why worth letting work full-time
and so some of the money was used for
spending like rent and just live a very
living cost okay all right so you didn't
work extra while you were in school so
guess what that means now you get to
work extra yes yes I do have a second
job now I do I'm like three jobs so yeah
good what is your household income with
your three jobs my household income is
about sixty thousand what do you teach I
am a special ed teacher okay I would
recommend you open up a side business
and the special ed community off
your services to parents who are of
means who have special needs kids to
have you around and they will pay you
very well by the hour better than better
than any Mickey Mouse part-time job you
would get and let's try to double your
income because you have a deep hole any
medium to small shovel right now you're
not afraid of hard work I heard that I'm
proud of you but you're you need to make
some money one hundred eighty-five
thousand dollars in student loan debt
you need to make a hundred a year and if
you're single and you do fifty thousand
a year then it's going to take you four
years to get out Wow